we woke up and it was exactly the
opposite it should be reassuring to find
two young men so engaged in an election
fed up with all the
all the bull crap and politics and we
know that we need to have good
freedom-loving candidates in office
and a trump branded pickup we're on the
campaign Trail in Pennsylvania and the
chat is about the candidates here
John Federman God forbid but if he was
elected to the Senate he'd be voting
with Biden voting with Kamala Harris 100
of the time
but here's the thing
these Disciples of Donald Trump have
been conned by his enduring
evidence-free claim they believe he won
the last election
if you thought this was a fringe view a
Lie peddled by Trump which can now be
dismissed as background noise we'll
think again
because as America heads to the polls
for this midterm take on the country's
Direction the anger the division cannot
be overstated America's at stake if we
if we lose it our country's going to
hell
I think I think it's a Civil War I I
truly do
really yes I I think that's I think
that's the only thing that's gonna
that's gonna bring America back together
after this election if we lose
that's an extraordinary frightening
prediction it is I mean but look look
back to
um
you know back in back in the old days on
that seemed to fix it the first time
so
it's not what you want it's not what I
want at all but I mean we're out of
options
knock knock
in search of maybe a more measured
nuanced perspective we went to meet a
different generation of Republicans at
their local party office which was an
invalid decision let's talk of conflict
here but what of the idea that they were
robbed in the last election so how many
of you here believe
that Donald Trump
should have won or did win the last
election absolutely did win
you all think the election was stolen by
Biden I don't even talk to Democrats
trying to convince them to change their
vote because it's like talking to a wall
they're out to lunch with the border
with drugs with crime with inflation
they've always got an excuse
but there's no answer
the solution is the trump-backed talk
show host and Doctor turned politician
he's been behind in the polls but is
closing on his rival
this man John fetterman the self-styled
salt of the earth man of the people
liberal
there's been plenty of talk about his
Fitness for office he had a stroke five
months ago and struggles with sentences
so what say his supporters this is about
a bigger challenge the biggest
there's lots of talk about the the
threat to Democracy in America do you
think that's overstated or do you think
genuinely there is there is a threat I
think it might be understated
um I think there's a genuine threat to
democracy in this country and it really
scares the hell out of me
[Music]
nothing on all the conversations here it
is kind of jolting there is so much
going on so many different issues a
growing division no doubt an absolutely
no trust between the two sides there's
anger for sure but I felt fear among
people too a real sense that they don't
know what comes next and they don't know
how they themselves would react to it
in the days ahead prepare for new claims
of fraud because here and in States
across the land communities in Echo
Chambers have been duped doubt has been
sewn into the fabric of American society
Mark Stone Sky News in Pennsylvania